there are not massive amounts of people
with military or intelligence experience
that are rising up through the ranks and
yet that's a pretty important element of
their job residential candidates on the
campaign Trail make all these promises
that they know nothing about they're
just promising what they're going to do
against Iran whatever they're saying
they have no idea until they basically
get to the last four people the last
four actually getting intelligence so
that they can start making reasonable
plans to the American people the
Democrats and the Republicans and as
they hear all of their debates with 8 to
12 candidates on each side none of those
candidates know what the hell they're
talking about they're making whatever
promise they truly believe will resonate
with their constituency not recognizing
that their entire foreign policy promise
could be undermined the day they get
that briefing they don't change their
campaign speech they make their promises
they get their briefing they keep their
promise even if they know they can't
fulfill it and then they get to the
White House and then they don't do what
they promise because the truth is once
you're actually the executive you have
to do what's in the best interest of the
nation and the best interest of the
nation isn't always the thing that got
you elected to office it's a tricky game
that they have to play